So I've got video today of just really good
work by CBS reporter Paula Reid yesterday.
I already told you that at the White House
Corona virus press briefing.
Donald Trump played this montage compilation
propaganda video whose creation
in and of itself might have actually violated
campaign finance laws because it was essentially
a campaign video produced by the administration
but by the administration and played at a
White House press briefing, despite the fact
that it's really more of a campaign ad.
And in the video, the narrative made the case
that at every opportunity, at every instance,
that every inflection.
Donald Trump did everything perfectly.
He did everything as early as he could have
done it.
He did everything as well and as efficiently
as it could have been done.
But the video that he played talks a lot about
what was going on in January before we had
our first case.
And then it skips February and talks a lot
about the decisions that Donald Trump made
in March.
It's like February didn't even happen, which
was actually the key month.
And that's when Donald
Trump should have been doing stuff.
But wasn't even the last 10 days of January
after our first case.
Donald Trump mostly golfed and did nothing
other than downplaying the threat of the virus.
So CBS is Paula Reid.
Good for her.
Confronts Donald Trump and says your video
skips February.
What the hell were you doing in February?
My words, not hers.
And Trump doesn't like to be confronted, especially
not by reporters, especially not by female
reporters.
We know that.
And it went about the way you would expect
it to go that you bought the argument is that
you bought yourself some time.
You didn't just to prepare hospitals, you
didn't use it to ramp up testing.
Right.
So you show what I'm you.
So disgraceful.
It's so disgraceful the way you said it.
Let me just listen.
I just went over it.
I just went over the unprecedented crime.
Nobody thought we should do it.
And when I did it, what did you do with the
time that you.
You know we did it, right?
Yeah, we did.
What do you do?
February.
What do you do when you have no case in a
whole United States when you.
Excuse me.
So I want to stop here briefly, because this
is important.
The video skips February.
Why does it skip February?
What Trump keeps talking about, January 17,
January 17.
We have no cases.
We had no cases.
What was I going to do?
Our first case was January 20th.
This is a calculated disinformation tactic.
Trump picks a day 72 hours before the first
case and says, what else was I gonna do at
that point?
Then he skips to what he did in March.
The whole point is and Paula Reed's questioning
is about the ten day period after the first
case.
Right.
January 20 to January 31.
That's when you should have been doing things.
And you golfed.
South Korea developed a test, rolled it out
widely isolated people, developed fever clinics,
did contact tracing South Korea.
To this day, has 222 deaths, not per day total.
That's
not a typo total.
South Korea has two to two deaths.
Fifteen hundred people died in the U.S. just
yesterday alone because during this key period,
January 20 to 31, Trump did nothing.
And that's why he keeps talking about January
17.
Let's continue.
You reported it.
Zero cases, zero deaths on January 17th the
entire year.
I said in June we got on January 30, the time
that your travel ban.
A lot.
And in fact, we'll give you a list.
What we did, in fact, part of it was up there.
We did a lot.
So here, Trump having to fall back on.
We'll give you a list of what we did, which
some flunky can come up with later, which
will, of course, be mostly bogus.
And it was in the video.
Well, it wasn't in the video.
That's the whole point of what Paula Reid
is asking about the February.
The entire month of February is missing from
the video that you played.
Let's look at just a little more of this.
And Trump becomes furious with Paula Reid.
She's doing a good job.
He attacks her as fake.
He says most of the reporters in the room
are also fake.
You know, you're a fake.
You know that your whole network, the way
you cover it, is fake.
And most of it and not all of you, but the
people are wise to you.
That's why you have a lower a lower approval
rating than you've ever had before.
Times probably three.
And when you ask me that question, let me
ask you this.
Why didn't Biden why didn't why did Biden
apologize?
Why did he write a letter of apology not care?
Oh, that's very important.
Paul, why did the Democrats think that I acted
too quickly?
You know why?
Because they really thought that I acted too
quickly.
Nothing.
Nothing screams confidence like attacking
the reporter and talking about Joe Biden.
Right.
So we are in an authoritarian nightmare.
The attacks on the press won't stop.
And meanwhile, Trump continues to mismanage
every element of this.
We have to get him out.
That's why I'm with Bernie, who says we've
got to vote for Biden.
That's why I'm with Noam Chomsky, who says
we must remove Trump.
And Biden won't be exciting, but he will clearly
be much better than Trump.
We have to do it.
This has to stop.
We'll have more about this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show.
And remember, follow my 2020 urban gardening
experience by following me on Instagram at
David Pakman.
I've got my raised beds built.
I've got dirt showing up soon.
I guess it's called soil, maybe dirt.
Dirt calling it dirt suggestion.
Which is right.
But in any case, follow the adventure at David
Pakman